in the world of under the dome we've got
no internet no mobile signals and barely
any radio communications how are you
guys cope if that were the case in real
life I just wouldn't I feel like if you
know if I'd grown up without those
things then then it wouldn't it wouldn't
be any different but having those things
and taking them away I would that's my
skin's I just don't know what I would
get freaked out that I suppose is where
you see the generational divide because
I have fantasies all the time about the
Internet going out and going back to a
time when things were simpler and slower
I'm sure in reality I would probably
have a nervous breakdown
but there's something quite wonderful
about going thinking about going back to
the time when we actually considered a
dining table and have a dinner without
someone picking up the phone and texting
in the middle of it you know so I've had
that cousin like that here because um
being from the US our phones don't work
over here and let's just get like a
special plan so um it's hard to get him
to work you have to be under Wi-Fi all
this stuff so it's kind of been like
that I guess at first I was crazy but I
actually don't mind it yeah being
disconnected is totally great sometimes
one of our show runners Jack bender who
also did lost was very open to us being
able to completely create our characters
and make them our own as well as having
his input and Stephen King's input but I
think we were able to make or at least I
was I was able to make nori a lot like
myself in some ways and another way
she's a little bit more crazy than me
but um for the most part yes definitely
I feel like I got to create her which
was very cool no no I definitely feel
like Joe as a character is really really
intelligent and by all means I don't
think that I'm like crazy intelligent
but I you know I really value like
learning and stuff and I actually feel
like I learned a lot from my character
while I was shooting even so developing
him and working with Jack bender and all
of the other show runners and the other
cast members as well it was really great
in developing you know my character and
and everyone else's so it was kind of
interesting for me and for Aisha because
as our characters were not in the book
so I've actually worked on a couple of
other Stephen King projects before and
I've always really loved the opportunity
to turn to the book and really find such
great character detail I think that's
one of the things that I I loved so much
about his writing so honestly I mean it
was wonderful in some ways to make it up
but I remember running into him when we
were rehearsing and and mr. King and I
was actually in the gym on the treadmill
and and he came in and he kind of
wandered in and was like do they have
headphones in here and I was like what
do I do
like he's in a twilight t-shirt and
shorts he's about to run and it's 8
o'clock in the morning and do I ask him
anything and and then I eventually
introduced myself and I was like I've
worked on your stuff before Salem's Lot
did it it was like what do you think
about Alice he's like hey man you know
they created it it's been different so
ask the you know the showrunners so it
was it's always great to have that
flexibility but I love his writing so
much and how specific he is with
characters that I yeah I didn't I didn't
I would have liked to have gotten a
little bit more of that from him this is
the first time I'd ever been to like a
like a comic-con event you know signing
or anything and so this is so fun for me
like I just had a blast just worth like
meeting everyone and just getting talk
to them and and and you know learning
which shows that you know that the fans
like you know whether it's on the dome
or you know stuff you worked on in the
past like finding out what what they
enjoyed and why is really cool too so I
love it my sister's actually played
Sophia on The Walking Dead so I've been
to many many Comic Cons and different
events like this so but it's it's so
cool to see what they appreciate up like
about the show they appreciate different
things different characters it's just
it's good to see that there is excited
as we are so that's very humbling and
sweet it's always you know when you're
working on television or in film you
don't have that connection of having the
opportunity to really talk to the fans
and find out specifically what
performance has meant something to
someone and what they're enjoying about
the show you're in such a vacuum in
regarde so yeah it's really fun to meet
people and see you know that your work
has meant something to them twitter has
been cool um we have live tweeted every
episode in the u.s. that was fun um and
so people are sitting there watching the
show with you essentially and so you get
their instant reaction which is
something that I think it's fairly new
yeah to live tweet but um I enjoyed that
because it's just such a you feel like
you get to I don't know it's just kind
of a bonding thing
I think it's specifically about the live
tweets I think it's cool that when you
know when we did that people would have
there's a lot I mean with the show like
this there's a lot of questions that go
on a lot of things that you know if you
mean even if you get up to go into the
kitchen and make something you're going
to miss something you know 30 min 30
seconds so people hop on Twitter and ask
us questions and being able to be there
and answer questions if we can
it was really cool because you know if
we can help them understand it more than
they'll like it wow the people inside
the dough have had their own questions
about what the dome is where it's come
from
have you had your own theories about
those questions as a series has gone
along and what are they I mean I
wouldn't really venture to share my
theories we've certainly all asked each
other a lot of questions and and ask
questions of the creators but but we
really it's up to the audience I think
to sort of decide what they think it is
and the cool thing about the dome for us
as the characters and the actors is um
we kind of got to act with it so it's
almost like another character like the
dome was you know just like nori er Joe
or Alice um so it was kind of like it
wasn't it was hard to theorize about
because it was almost like it was
another person in the show um but we all
had different questions we were all we
all talked about it but um you'll find
out more in the last three episodes I I
don't I definitely think that you know I
have I have my own theory of like what
the dome is and stuff but like it
changes for sure like you know when we
were shooting we would get the scripts
for our next episode a couple days
before we were set to shoot it so I mean
like we would learn new bits of
information while we're shooting and
then therefore our thoughts would change
based on what's you know what's going to
happen so I'm
I really you know season 2 will bring
new things and new theories for for all
of us we don't text each other did you
read it
hey what do you think you know what's
gonna what do we thinks gonna happen
next you know what's in the next one